la crisis política en Venezuela no es
nueva ni tampoco lo son los intentos de
conversaciones entre el gobierno y la
oposición en medio de pedidos de
destitución del presidente Nicolás
maduro y una atención política ambas
partes se reunían en Caracas en 2016
unas negociaciones acompañadas por el
Vaticano España Panamá y República
Dominicana Entonces el gobierno se
mostraba optimista queremos hacer
nuestras palabras de saludo del
presidente Y comprometernos de forma
profunda a que este diálogo tenga
resultados certeros y rápidos pero los
intentos de una salida dialogada se
desvanecieron rápidamente ambos bandos
lo intentaron de nuevo en República
Dominicana La entonces jefa de la
asamblea constitucional recalcaba la
relevancia del diálogo en 2017 la única
vía para Venezuela es el diálogo es la
paz no hay otra vida no podemos permitir
que las órdenes imperiales que los
poderes fácticos se impongan una agenda
de violencia en el suelo una agenda de
guerra pero las partes fallaron en
encontrar una fecha para unas elecciones
presidenciales y los diálogos entraron
en un receso indefinido las
conversaciones se reanudaron en Barbados
en 2019 pero maduro decidió levantarse
de la mesa por el apoyo de la oposición
a las sanciones económicas impuestas a
Venezuela por parte de Estados Unidos
Ciudad de México habría una nueva
esperanza de llegar a una salida a la
crisis política Venezuela está mal está
muy mal
nuestro pueblo sufre la peor crisis de
su historia contemporánea
agradecimiento y aunque las partes
lograron llegar a una serie de acuerdos
las conversaciones fracasaron luego del
pedido de los representantes del
gobierno te incorporar al diálogo al
empresario Colombo venezolano alexap
había sido pedido una extradición por
parte de Estados Unidos que lo acusaba
de lavado de activos